foreign
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
Rodrigo and Greta the Dream Team behind
Barbie and it's so exciting so my first
question for you you spent the entire
day looking at Barbie in IMAX what are
your thoughts just straight off of
getting to review the film and on our
screens
all of my I mean first of all that it's
it sounds and looks incredible like this
is the most satisfying way to watch it
for me and it feels like it really gets
you know inside you and I like the
feeling of being you know nearly
overwhelmed by it
um that's exciting so that that feels
very um wonderful but then obviously
when we were sitting together I feel
like all I can like
you we're looking at what really is that
right is this you know so we're we're
doing our own version of being hyper
critical but also then I'm like a stand
back and I said this looks amazing and
you see every single detail so
everything including whatever it might
be a defect that we hadn't even noticed
before right but uh I I it seems to me
like we had always planned to do the
movie for IMAX somehow yes you know it
works so well on this big screen it just
it's it works very well it was also the
way
um with the proportions and the sort of
format the way we shot it and and that
aspect ratio it it has that quality of
making her look you know
filled screen vertically as a doll which
we'd always talks about dolls need
vertical space
um because they're you know top to
bottom but then it also has a quality
even though it's huge it somehow
contains it so it makes it more
doll-like I don't know how to explain it
it somehow it doesn't make it seem like
uh it does something strange to the
scale yeah there's something about a two
to one aspect ratio that's for the
everywhere we see it that way but for
the in IMAX it works amazingly I mean
the moment in the 2001 sequence when you
see her in the bang and exactly had to
tell in the little girl at the bottom
and on this big screen you see her like
this and you see the little girl like
that you know you're actually moving
your head around and it was really yeah
and also in the seeing all the details
and everything like things that we've
done that are purposefully
almost homemade looking and again the
transportation sequences like the wires
of everything which in some formats you
don't see as well in this you can see
the wires of the Butterflies what
attached and it makes it um
I don't know it's pleasing to me that
you can see all the mechanics of it
because
I want people to see the mechanics the
first time I noticed some of those I
know yeah uh one thing I did want to ask
both of you is for fans could you
explain why they should experience
Barbie and IMAX both for fans that have
seen the movie but also fans that are
kind of this is one of the last chances
to see it theatrically well I mean you
know the whole time we were making it I
kept thinking of um
you know I mean it goes back to writing
it there was um
there were no movie theaters at the
moment like people were going to the
movie theaters and even when we were
prepping it was like just starting to
come back and I just kept imagining
making something so loud like outrageous
and and so that like
so Bananagrams and outlandish that you'd
want to be in a room full of people
experiencing it together and so I always
had the sense of people kind of sitting
in the dark and being together on this
uh just
totally wild journey and I think that in
that bigness it's like this is the the
biggest of the big yeah and also there's
something about the combination of it so
it's so um Larger than Life and then the
way the sound and the music goes
together it's like it really is inside
you it's um well it's like a it's in an
11 right like they're saying
um
um spinal tap right
yes but not literally
but in metaphorically it's an 11. yeah
it's it's very impactful I mean the
movie is already and and yeah I saw it
in the cinema as well in Mexico City
actually and and it was great but seeing
it on this big screen with the sound
it's a new experience and I think that
the movie is an experience but this
really takes it to another level plus a
bonus material
yeah is there any any cryptic teas you
can put out there as to what fans should
expect with the never before seen well
yeah well I will say that I mean it was
the most joyful set I think I've ever
ever been around it was like it was the
colors it was the it was the you know
performers it was Rodrigo it was it was
like the most wonderful place to be so
um I I would say there was this sort of
joy that I think you can kind of
palpably feel in the movie it was
actually there in the shoot so there is
some kind of look at that behind the
scenes and then also just as as things
go in movies there's just a million
little
um diamonds that were not we didn't we
didn't have space for every Diamond so
this was also a chance for me to get
some some jokes and I'll say I'll say
far to Opera
I mean I'm not I'm
that's amazing you know even even when
when I saw the film I was like oh I
loved it I love everything about it but
I was like oh I remember this thing we
did but of course it didn't fit but so
now there's a chance to see some of
those so yeah in your mind you're like
the fart Opera for sure very
sophisticated you need to see it in iMac
yes yes otherwise they unpack otherwise
you wouldn't feel it under your seats
and you wouldn't know yeah we wouldn't
be funny or Dramatics sure
that's the entire pitch right yeah yeah
I mean yeah I was sold where you walked
in
um last question and this is something
we love to ask our filmmaker friends you
know this has become kind of a popular
question but if there is any movie you
could experience again or for the first
time in IMAX for both of you
um what would come to mind is something
you would love to experience again well
obviously the one I ripped off 2001.
like I mean like 2001. I mean that's
pretty overwhelming all the time but
yeah that's a good one for sure I would
say Raging Bull this is just my favorite
movie and then I think it's spectacular
in every way and I'd love to see those
black and white images in the big screen
like that that would be my choice it
would be amazing it's pretty amazing
thank you both for your time we really
appreciate it and for sitting down with
us this is amazing Blade Runner would be
good runner would be oh my God that's a
great choice yeah that rain yeah because
that lighting yeah oh my God you could I
literally like think about this topic in
my sleep like I try to wake up I have a
new answer every day though it was like
it's endless yeah yeah you'll have a
million I know
foreign